- Non, non, ça fait 10-15 ans
que je suis pas allé dans
un bar, là.
- François Pérusse, musicien,
humoriste, comédien,
vous incarnez un des rôles
principaux dans le film
de Guillaume Lambert, "Niagara".
Mais pourquoi vous mettre ainsi
en danger? C'est quoi? C'est
Guillaume Lambert qui vous
a convaincu?
FRANÇOIS PÉRUSSE, humoriste,
auteur-compos.-interprète,
- Guillaume y est pour beaucoup.
J'aiccccepté ce projet-là parce
que j'aime bien la personne
qui me l'a proposée. Il m'a
rassuré. Puis pourquoi y a
pensé à moi? C'est... il
m'a expliqué que quand je ne
souriais pas, j'avais un air
grave. Puis c'est vrai, j'ai
l'air grave quand je souris pas.
Au point, ma conjointe peut
dire : "Est-ce que ça va?"
Oui, ça va, j'étais juste en
train de penser à qu'est-ce que
je vais acheter à l'épicerie.
Mais, j'ai l'air grave quand
je souris pas et puis un peu
ma façon de m'exprimer, ma façon
d'être, mon visage, mes...
Il voyait dans mon langage
corporel, que je correspondais
au personnage auquel il avait
pensé, et j'ai fait confiance
en Guillaume. J'ai dit : OK,
allons-y.
♪♪ Deux minutes ♪
♪ Deux minutes ♪
Bonjour!
Le8 8 octobre 1991, j'avais
31 ans.
- Le tome 1 de l'Album du peuple
à célébrer ses 30 ans l'an
dernier.
- Oui.
- L'Album du peuple c'est
15 disques, 2 millions
d'exemplaires vendus. Je me
suis toujours posé la question :
comment, à quel moment vous ezez
décidé d'accélérer des voix pour
en faire de l'humour. Quel jou?
Un samedi matin ensoleillé?
- J'avais 8 ans, j'avais
un magnétophone qui appartenait
à mon père qui fonctionnait sur
piles et j'enregistrais ma voix
sur des cassettes. Je faisais
des fausses publicités,
je faisais... je m'amusais
à enregistrer, je faisais
des niaiseries, je trouvais
ça bien rigolo. Et
j'enregistrais ça sur
un appareil à pile et je m'en
rendais pas compte, mais
les piles faiblissent. À
un moment donné, la bande,
le moteur faiblissait aussi,
il tournait plus lentement.
Mais... ça donnait pas une
impression d'accélération,
ça donnait l'impression que ça
allait de plus en plus lentement
plutôt. Et puis, à un moment
donné, mon père a acheté
un adaptateur électrique pour
faire fonctionner l'appareil.
J'ai réécouté mes bandes avec
le moteur qui tourne à
la vitesse normale et là,
c'était hyper... hyper aigu et
plus accéléré et j'ai trouvé
ça tordant.
- Oui, mais qu'est-ce i i s'est
passé de 8 ans à 30 ans parce
que le succès est venu tard
pour vous. Il y a eu 12 ans
de radio communautaire...
- C'est vrai.
- ... à Québec. Puis là,
à 30 ans, pouf! Le succès!
- J'ai commencé à jouer de la
basse avec Luc de Laroelellière
par le truchement de mon frère,
qui était son chef d'orchestre.
Et c'est tombé dans l'oreille
de Luc et son gérant, Pierre
Dumont, qui est mon gérant
aujourd'hui et de mon frère,
et tout ça, qui ont décidé de
me faire faire une publicité.
Pour annoncer l'album "Sauvez
mon âme", sur lequel j'ai joué,
en utilisant cette technologie-
là et mes textes et tout ça pour
faire un 30 secondes. Je l'ai
fait, ça a joué dans toutes
les radios du Québec et j'ai
eu un appel de CKOI, à l'époque.
C'est comme ça que ça
a commencé.
"Raccroche donc ça
ce téléphone-là! Aweille,
raccroche ça toi là!"
"C'est quoi le disque que
tu veux?"
"L'album du peuple tome 2!"
- Mon personnage préféré,
c'est le gars qui magasine avec
Mona!
- Mona!
(rire)
Mona!
- Qui vous a inspiré dans
la vraie vie pour ces
personnages-là?
- À un moment donné, il y a
quelqu'un avec qui j'ai
travaillé pas longtemps dans
un magasin sur la rue Caieier
à Québec. Je l'écoutais parler
à ses fournisseurs. Il était
un petit peu... un petit peu
baveux, t'sais.
"Oui OK d'abord, si je l'ai pas
demain je vais l'avoir quand?
À Noël?"
Il parlait de même, puis ça
m'a inspiré un peu un baveux
qui parle au téléphone puis
qui ridiculise tout ce que
son interlocuteur dit.
Il n'y a pas de nom ce gars-là,
c'est le gars qui magasine,
j'ai jamais donné de nom et
je peux plus lui en donner un.
Ça fait trop longtemps qu'il a
pas de nom, il est baptisé rien.
"Oui?"
"Bon anniversaire voil d des
ballons et deux petits clowns!"
- Je veux parler de votre succès
en France. Huit ans de capsules,
huit ans de reprise, vous êtes
une mégastar là-bas, on vous
reconnait quasiment dans la rue,
là!
- 75 % des membres de ma chaîne
Youtube so d des Européens
francophones. Je suis le premier
surpris. Je vois votre surprise,
je suis surpris aussi.
- Mais ils comprennent vos
blagues, vos expressions?
- Et bien, il a fallu que
je mdadapte, alors j'ai même
un accent. J'en ai refait
une couple récemment et je
me ss s aperçu que c'est pas
les mêmes muscles que pour
l'accent québécois. Ça faisait
lolongtemps que j'avais pas paré
en français international et
c'est pas les mêmes muscles,
c'est pas les mêmes totonations,
là. T'sais... on dit pas
"longtemps", on dit "longtemps".
♪ ♪ ♪
- François Pérusse, je termine
en vous remerciant parce qu'il y
a plus de 25 ans vous avez psésé
deux heures, vous travailliez
24 heures sur 24 à l'époque...
vous aviez passé deux heures
avec un jeune journalie e pour
l'encourager.
- Oh!
- Et il a continué
ce journalisteàà à faire
le métier, donc merci beaucoup
François Pérusse.
- Mais c'est donc bien
fantastie!e!
- Merci!
- C'est donc bien beau!
- Vous aussi.
- J'ai... c'est... c'est
fantastique. Ça, ça fait
ma semaine ça. Ça, çfafait
vraiment ma semaine.
♪ 10 millions de vues ♪